but there's another story breaking here
just to interrupt this in a little bit
i'm seeing a lot of comments about the
new york times
obtaining private communications from
project veritas that was given to them
by the fbi will chamberlain is tweeting
about this tucker carlson just did a
segment about this i was i was just
looking at my phone as you guys were
going at it but this is a major story uh
of the fbi leaking the private
communications of project veritas these
are some of the preliminary reports and
giving it to the new york times that's
the preliminary reports that are coming
out right now uh
reporting about the legality of it i
mean this is just yet another horrendous
example those are illegals
that is becoming more bastardized and
more political by the day yeah i have i
stated this in response so there's a
story that uh progressives are calling
for a mistrial on the right house case
because the judge's phone played god
bless the usa and i said as millennials
age into power
the divide in this country will become
more and more extreme and the united
states is dissolution seems inevitable
when the fbi
raids a journalistic enterprise to leak
their communications to another rival
ideological institution who then
gleefully publishes that information
this is what i'm saying about cultural
homogeneity the journalists at the new
york times should have said we will
never publish this that's a egregious
violation instead they're like ooh
because they are uh
you we are we are a culturally
bifurcated society will youtube i'm
sorry not youtube will twitter allow
people to tweet about it like the the
hunter biden laptop or will they not
allow tweets because it was obtained
illegally remember
their standard is you can't tweet about
stuff that was obtained illegally i
think it's pretty clear what they're
going to do what fits with their agenda
but to be clear the fbi this is what
mike cernovich is saying quote the fbi
leaked attorney client
privileged communications from those
devices to the new york times so this is
a major story that's just developing
right now that a lot of people have been
telling me here in the comment section
but uh this seems it seems very big and
just yet another sign of just how
politically biased and insane our
current social political climate is
right now because i mean if these
allegations that we're seeing these
people are evil i'm asking myself adam
goldman of the new york times
evil
we've got to stop playing these games
this is a guy who got privileged legal
communications under the united states
constitution and our laws and norms you
do you have a right to legal counsel and
the guy the new york times gleefully
published this from a rival organization
why they want this country to burn they
want power and they will get it by any
means necessary and they will use the
power of the federal government to do it
i am looking at all of you right now and
i am telling you this the police will
kick your door in and bash your teeth
out the moment black lives matter
protests you we've already seen it
happen you think this is a joke james
o'keefe's legal privileged
communications were just given to the
new york times and adam goldman with a
smile on his face published it he
doesn't care about this country he
doesn't care about our norms these
people are at war with you and they will
burn your life to the ground like
they're doing a written house and like
they're doing now to james o'keefe
because you dare oppose their power grab
this is not a joke and it is getting
worse and in the next 10 years as we
enter the fourth turning and it
escalates it is going to get worse james
o'keefe is a journalist the federal
government stole his privileged legal
communications and gave it to the new
york times who published it with a smile
on their faces
these people do not hold your values
they do not believe in the constitution
the prosecutor in the written house case
violated the constitution they will do
it again they will do it more and they
will burn down your town and the feds
will protect them and the police will
protect them stop thinking the
institutions are on your side this
country is being corrupted and we are
watching it every day and it has gotten
to the point where you need to ask
yourself
will the police protect you when someone
comes to your town and threatens to kill
you
no the detectives in kenosha the state
the prosecutor went against the the
young man who was fleeing for his life
and james o'keefe
an anti-establishment individual and i i
mean that with respect but he is
outright just a journalist
is facing the boot
of the authoritarian fascist government
and it will get worse and it will happen
to you because you keep complying and
you keep saying but my kids need food
and now inflation is here and there's
food shortages and your kids aren't
eating and the schools are
indoctrinating your kids
now we see a turnaround with yunkan
because the parents are standing up but
too many people keep saying as long as i
keep fellating the state and dropping on
my knees for the far left extremists i
will squeak by and you will not the
police will come to your home they will
kick your door in and they will arrest
you because the good cops have already
started quitting and like we saw in
seattle the police arrested the man who
was retreating from antifa as antifa
approached it with clubs in hand and
they apologized to antifa over it like
we saw in the chairs when when when
several men unloaded hundreds of rounds
into an suv and then the extremists
stripped the evidence from the vehicle
and none of those people are brought to
justice and now we are at the point
where project veritas is having their
private privileged legal communications
leaked to the to the new york times who
with a smile on their face violate all
norms
all respect and lack all scruples and
you think sitting back and complying
will result in you getting by you are
wrong
i'm
sick of this
preach
yeah what do you do when the fbi is
violating the constitution because you
can't call anyone at that point there's
no one no more authority to appeal to
you have to create your own i mean i i
don't trust anyone in government because
they don't they're you know even the
good ones are weak i i like to think
right now rand paul is calling merrick
garland or rand paul is calling
christopher wray saying
what's going on guys like uh you know
but even then they're just gonna laugh
and say you're in the minority what are
you gonna do bring me to a hearing they
couldn't get it done when they were in
the majority no exactly the republicans
agreed with russiagate no they did
nothing yeah
and now i i i can't believe
i don't think people understand the
severity of what we're witnessing right
now with project veritas no hearing this
story breaking right now on this show is
basically what you need to understand we
are in
a neo-communist
fascist we need a new word for it
state
authoritarian whatever this is technic
technocracy man
is has had evidence
of crimes committed in kenosha nothing
was done the state prosecutor instructed
the detectives not to execute a search
warrant on gage gross kreutz who came
with a concealed weapon illegally
to a riot
and the state said no no don't execute
the warrant against him they are burning
the country to the ground they're
getting away with it the fbi is not on
the side of justice right they are on
the side of targeting you your friends
they will come for you given time you
think maybe you can hide among the
masses but eventually when when when the
turkeys are all lined up not a single
turkey gets by all of their heads get
removed project veritas just happens to
be one of the groups with a longer neck
james o'keefe stands up and speaks out
and goes after the power structure
and the new york times is a is a vassal
of the authoritarian state they are a
weapon wielded by the authoritarians who
have taken over this country and are
taking away our rights and they are
raiding the homes of journalists
this is
i i i just hope you all understand that
this moment right now will go down in
infamy you will remember where you were
when you learned the fbi began targeting
american journalists because in a year
in two years when there no longer exists
any free press
you will ask yourself how is it that we
that we've gotten to this point where
we're hiding underground where we're
fleeing our homes where we've decided
it's no longer safe to live in this
country and you will think back to the
day that project veritas was raided by
the fbi and their legally their legal
rights were violated and that other
journalistic institutions gleefully
basketball in this james o'keefe is the
canary in the coal mine let's not let
him die yes let's not let him go down we
i mean seriously our opinions our voices
do matter uh the protests do matter
us getting involved does matter if
you're gonna
put your tail between your legs if
you're gonna hide you're gonna get hit
sooner or later there's no escaping
there's no running away from this it's
time to face it and to do everything in
our power legally peacefully safely uh
to raise awareness persuasive and
resourceful exactly the problem is that
i have i had a conversation recently
where someone said i'm sick of the
mandates i refuse to work in an
environment where they're gonna make me
get booster shots
and i'm going to vote democrat
and i'm like i'll be honest i don't
think republican gets you out of here
either you know but this idea that
people can keep sticking their hand into
the fire and eventually get by no i
think what we need are people to just
start overtly telling their jobs telling
the businesses no
i will not comply i refuse
in new york city
they have lied
in san francisco in l.a they have lied
they have stated we've always had
vaccine mandates no
we've never had a circumstance in which
you were denied public accommodation
because the because you refuse a
government mandated medical procedure
yeah
there are there are small things you can
do i mean people sometimes they feel
powerless and they they they want to
push back
um and and how do you because most of
the things we need to survive come from
huge corporations and huge corporations
are easily but are
are everywhere they're omnipresent but
there are there are small things you can
do like one of the simplest ones i
closed my bank of america account that i
didn't have a ton of money but my direct
deposit of my paycheck i had my loan
through them took all my money i went to
a small little bank of clark county
because i live on credit union rural
virginia or a credit union yeah and when
they said why do you want to close your
accounts i said because your
philanthropy and your billion dollars to
black lives matter i can't be part of
that if you have profits you're making
it from me and i can't be part so there
are little small things you can do in
those decisions that you make you can't
necessarily get rid of your iphone you
can't necessarily but i want to say
first and foremost right now what you
need to do
is
google search your local representatives
your state rep your state senator
win these elections
because if the states can get to a
convention of states we can solve this
very quickly
that's where we start that's what needs
to be done
get prepared for the midterm elections
and primary the establishment
republicans and the neocons
get in the national populists and the
the more libertarian-minded individuals
look at what new hampshire is doing with
the free state project that's victory i
also want to make sure i read this one
uh super chat someone pointed out
regina ponte says obama went after james
rosen you are correct absolutely obama
went after more whistleblowers under the
espionage act than all other presidents
combined obama was a monster and a
tyrant and we got donald trump after him
now we're back to the o to obama's
administration it's just biden biden is
basically obama 2.0 of course it's
getting this bad
let's read super chats because man that
really lit me up dude
james o'keefe may be one of the only
investigative journalists we have left
there there are many smaller individuals
but this is a guy who i've made i've
said it over and over again he is
angering the powers that be he's one of
the few people willing to stand up to
the machine
and it's no surprise to me
that we've reached this point where
they're doing this and this isn't just
going after one journalist it's going
after an organization and all of their
reporters
so before we go to super chats i just
want to say earlier today i tweeted um
that the
uh black lives matter and new york city
is talking about burning the place to
the ground and the fbi is doing things
like investigating james o'keefe i don't
think anyone is coming to save us so
it's up to us so we need to figure out
what we're gonna do about it no one will
save you florida save yourself new
hampshire yep texas
west virginia yes west virginia i think
is the worst of the bunch maybe virginia
oh come on maybe i mean there was some
resistance but i i i don't think the
republican party is the path no to
freedom or victory but primary right
primarying these these establishment uh
actors it is still possible
we can do this peacefully with
persuasion and resource
we've just never tried before
i think right now we are very very close
to a convention of states because at the
state level you have more
um honest and freedom-loving individuals
we have to stop seeding power to the
federal government we need states to
start standing up so vote google search
right now who your state rep and state
senator are look at that state senator
uh durr in in in new jersey
we need more people to vote for
good individuals it doesn't mean
republican doesn't mean democrat
typically it means no democrats though
but i don't think it's a guarantee
you're going to get a good republican
but in the free state project in new
hampshire they're using the republican
party as their vehicle towards freedom
and it's working thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time